here now victor davis hanson senior
fellow at the hoover institute uh victor
always loved talking to you uh these
things happen for a reason why are we
seeing what we're seeing in this
particular
instance with train cars but it tells a
larger story
we're going back to the 1880s western
old west train robberies and we're going
back to 1970s crime as we saw in new
york or 1980s inflation or foreign
policy in the mid 70s
when we left vietnam i think what
academics i don't want to quote them but
they call this systems collapse where
all of a sudden a successful society
suddenly doesn't follow its tradition
and rules and things happen that people
cannot believe such as empty shelves or
you're not able to buy me or you go to
fill up your your car and it's a hundred
dollars for just 18 gallons or people
getting shot in the street or people
outright racist ideology being taught in
the schools and all of these things
start to unwind a society so the point
is that
it can't continue when you look at those
train tracks and that trash you say this
this is not a third world country but it
is just like market street in san
francisco just like the subway in new
york just like the school system in
virginia so it's all unwinding i think
finally pete we really have to redefine
this whole woke ideology we think it's
kind of cute or it's incompetent or it's
left-wing or it's marxist it's cruel
it's mean it tells the you me every
citizen if you get hurt you get shot
we're not going to worry about you and
the person who did that to you is
probably going to be out without
on bail or not prosecuted for an earlier
crime it tells a young child you in the
present are going to learn good racism
because there were bad racism in the
past it tells the old guy it's 768 like
me if you need treatment you may be the
wrong color you wait in line this is a
regression it's a very evil ideology
because it's cruel it's mean-spirited
and we haven't talked about that but
that's what it is and it won't end if
people start identifying it like that
it's a stupid mean-spirited ideology
it's anti-humanistic
and uh what a great way to put it out
against cruelty because it has a history
throughout the centuries and it doesn't
end well
well you study this uh and you
understand how systems collapse what is
the crucial moment what is the crucial
point what leads to the beginning of
something like what we're
seeing i i think it's when the the law
is in
is asymmetrically applied or not applied
at all when some when you see somebody
walk out of a store with a bag of
goods and does not pay and nobody says
anything or you see somebody take uh
just go to a car and steal it and you
know nothing's going to happen
or you see something like waukesha or
they're hostage taking in texas and the
media won't cover it
or you see crimes that won't be reported
for political reasons and when the
system can't react and the then the
person in the middle the citizen says i
don't i don't believe anymore when you
look at the cia the fbi the irs the doj
the pentagon these were once esteemed
maybe not the irs but they were once
esteemed agencies people have no
confidence in them anymore and that's
what starts to unwind when you look what
the career of a fauci a millie a clapper
a comey a mccabe people said
these aren't the people that that we
trust
we're more we used to love the
government now we fear the government
and so the government's lost credibility
morality and we've got to restore it by
all of these das have to prosecute
crimes you have to be arrested you have
to be indicted if you're guilty you have
to serve your time to regain confidence
and make it safe to be a human again
we're not humans anymore we're we're
just
i don't know we're just
tinker toys in some grand woke game of
utopia and all these people who who
craft these ideas are never subject to
the consequences of their ideology
they're nancy pelosi behind walls up in
napa or
there are people in the upper west side
or their people
uh like mark zuckerberg and his hawaiian
estate but they're never subject and uh
if they were subject they would stop
very quickly i hope
but we've got to restore it's a great
point tradition custom
you're right uh victor davis hansen uh
you're talking about the politicization
of justice and when it isn't isn't
equally applied absolutely everything
else falls apart by the way if you agree
and like what victor davis hanson has to
say here he is prominently featured in
my new fox nation series miss education
of america we flew all the way out to
his almond farm in california to
interview him sit down and pick his
brain about how americans were educated
back when we actually educated liberated
citizens victor thanks for taking part
in that project our folks can watch in
on fox nation and thanks for being with
us tonight really really appreciate it
thank you for having me hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else